hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to crystal rift one of the
few games that is currently working with
the oculus rift dev kit - and that
ceiling is very close to my head
that claims to be horror whoa it is a
square base game meaning that Wow
then I am either really really tall this
dungeon is very small but it's a square
base whoa whoa whoa whoa okay then it's
a square based game which means that
it's you move in blocks so we're okay
there we go I got it got it moving
forward here we go okay so you have to
move in square blocks throughout the
game I'm too smart for you so you got to
travel through it whoa whoa whoa what is
that what does that sound whoa what is
up there ah tom tells me I don't want to
I really don't want to stand under that
but I almost feel obligated to so let's
go oh god okay alright then I was a damn
spider was that it doing this is a
looping spider oh so what am I supposed
to do how am I supposed to get over that
okay okay
I'm dead well then that's fun in a lot
of ways Oh pull all levers down Oh
ah oh those instructions would have been
very good to know so I gotta go fast
yeah yeah I gotcha
oh so the fog huh it's kinda like a
cheesy haunted house [ __ ] you ah I
thought of our best is out are you gonna
play this huh
after all I've done for you what's
what's awaiting me in there nothing ah
says are you gonna be huh a douche gonna
be the big douche that throws faces and
loud noises a me huh god damn it
hate to admit that that does get me woo
wooden again find the head and bought
can sit whoa I found it a perfect
apparently I found it and I'm going
through puberty also whoa what am I even
doing what is going on here what's going
on whoa hey woo that's green cool
what does that mean okay what am i doing
not again
suck a dong hai you son of a [ __ ] you
can't do that
ah it gives me cramps in my shoulders
yeah okay I'm riding a mini car now
oh wow you got throw something else at
me huh oh boy this is like a haunted
house SAG's account
fun riding a roller coaster that's cool
hello man look at that it's awesome I
feel like I'm a gnome going through
tunnels it's why I'd be scared of it
like a spider or some go turn no yeah
turn that way okay
go throw anything else at me you do it
again I swear I will is that a pit of at
oh that's a bit of water acid and blood
I'm guessing anything
Fay says anybody know okay so um
I feel pretty good
God hey looking up those things god it's
so weird that I can look down these old
like this us nuts that blood is blood
can hurt me apparently not okay one of
these things gonna have some minute
sons of [ __ ] I know you I know how
your game works look what happens when I
jump in the fire Oh dad are you here we
go poop yep whoa ghostly Anitha real me
I'm riding again
oh don't don't don't
okay it did not but I was worried who
did that what is doing that oh I see how
this is okay player cam you rug hi here
we go oh I double died I guess you can't
run into the spikes either
can I turn thank you hi one of those
days one of these days whoa I didn't
expect you to be there Oh what am I
doing this for why did I do that
do I get to go back okay here we go all
right got it got it yes I'm good I'm
good
Hey
hello ski I did I'm the best maybe
unless I'm doing something bad oh don't
don't don't
okay all right I just want to warn it
cuz if it does it again I'm gonna be
very upset what's what's a fire alright
anyway all right so that's that what's
that it's a thing wow wow wow wow wow
wow that Hoyt my face a lot okay big
giant Council so what about that okay
all right
okay what is the point of all this oh
okay
okay then okay we're good we're good
let's get out of here did we do it
did I do it did I do it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely
yes this is good it's good it's good I
got a bad feeling that they're gonna
throw us on mammy but this good okay so
far so good yes yes what is that 200 why
is it gonna be a series of mazes god
it's a freaking maze endless and all
that we owe your so don't do it
no yo no no no no no no no
okay all right then alone I hope so so
soon a few hundred thousand people watch
him Oh screw you don't do it don't you
oh god damn it what do i do what do i do
what do i do oh I don't like this I like
this I don't like this I like it what do
i do what do i do oh what do i do what
do i do what do i do what do i do what
do i do oh it's dark why can't I go that
way but can I can I
oh there's bars that's why I can't see
anything dark okay there we go uh-huh ha
ha ha ha
stupid game dick yeah can't stay
[ __ ] you oh I hate it are you gonna do
it hey you I hate you hate you I hate
you
okay maybe not thank you for playing is
it over find out more at crystal rift
calm huh please donate we need your help
follow us on twitter at crystal rift you
guys hear that
good sorry but this is the end are you
sure sure about that
okay what about that that looks like it
gets out of here okay okay where did I
go I start over on the beginning yeah
that's it okay all right then nothing to
worry about
I fully expect a dubstep remix of that
ASAP get on that musicians anyway Tom
all done here
whoa aside from the occasional douchery
those pretty cool is like very very
cramped in there you're claustrophobic
you would get that very easily in there
because the ceiling was literally like
on my eyebrow line the entire game and
the floor it was like I was crunched
down into a tiny ball had no idea how I
was crawling through there but either
way that was a lot of fun you heard the
information get to them thank you all so
much for watching you can check out all
my other oculus rift horror games in the
description below or through the
annotation over there thank you all so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
the entrails of the fallen on your face